Okay. Hello everyone. This is Mike Btos
and this is the order flows market
analysis for April 27, 2017. Uh it was
an interesting day. European Central
Bank left its policy unchanged and said
that rates would remain at present or
lower levels well past the horizon of
assets purchases and you got the second
round of French elections in about 2
weeks and with no updates to economic
forecasts you know on the schedule
people didn't really expect uh Draghi
ECB president to signal any major shift
in his policy in the US the markets you
know closed marginally higher Dow was up
about six points and S&Ps were up about
uh you know a point and you know five
ticks uh about 1.32 points in the cash.
We saw that
2388.77.
Um yeah it it was kind of a boring day
in the equity markets. Uh very tight
range but um there were some interesting
things to talk about in a couple of the
other markets crude especially. So, uh,
you know, before we jump in, got to go
through that disclaimer. Um, you know, I
don't want people coming in thinking,
"Oh yeah, order flows is the way that's
going to solve all my financial problems
and, uh, make me a millionaire by the
end of the year." No, you know, trading
takes work. It takes dedication. It
takes a willingness to learn. Um, if if
you don't have those qualities, then,
you know, trading is probably not for
you. I'm not going to say, you know, my
my way of trading is not for you or, you
know, order flow is not for you, but
trading in general is not for those that
don't want to put in the work. Yes,
there are the rare cases of people that
are just brilliant. Um, you know, but
honestly, the reason they're brilliant
is because they put in the work their
entire lives and they just make things
look easy. So, that's a brief
disclaimer. This presentation is for
educational andformational purposes only
and should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision. Futures trading
contain substantial risk and is not for
every investor. An investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment. Risk capital is
money that can be lost without
jeopardizing one's financial security or
lifestyle. Only risk capital should be
used for trading and only those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
trading. Past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future
results. You know, I have this in the
front of just about every single video I
put out there. Um, and again, I cannot
stress it enough. Um, you know, trading
is risky. Um, you know, I I laugh at
people. You know, I I see these posts on
on Facebook. There's a fella, you know,
Forex guy talks about, oh, you know,
hey, uh, you know, I've created this
system and it's got a 500% return. you
know, you open an account for $1,000 at
the end of 6
months, you know, you'll have $5,000
back. You know, who wants it? You know,
then there's a link there. Of course,
the draw down is was it 46% or 50%,
honestly, if you're trading, you got a
draw down of 56% or 40%, you know,
honestly, anything above 20% should be
setting up, you know, uh what do you
want to call it? Flashing lights. um you
know that that's not a healthy uh sign.
You know it's one thing to back test
something and say oh yeah look it had a
500% return but you know if if you don't
handle the 50% draw down you know most
funds will close after you know before
you even get to a draw down like that.
So, you know, for people that all of a
sudden think that, hey, a 50% draw down.
Yeah, that's fine. You know, I'm just
taking a a punt, you know, I'm investing
a,000 to try and get five five, you
know, 5,000 back, get a 500% return. I'm
willing to risk that. Yeah. Okay. Well,
why don't you just go to the casino and,
you know, make a straight, you know, or
go to the the sports book and, you know,
bet on a sporting event. um you know why
sit around for five months hoping that
you know you get some return back you
know just go to casino and and piss away
your money um you know you got about as
much chance as as you do with a system
like that but um you know that's just my
own two cents you know I mean I wouldn't
want to spend 5 months pissing away you
know half my money and hoping that yeah
I could catch that that that 500% return
but you know I've got just a equal
chance of of practically blowing out. So
anyway, the tools used in this
presentation is the order flows trader.
A couple other tools uh I'll be talking
about um you know the free one, the
delta surge, the delta scalper which is
not free, it's paid, the price rejector,
um transition, voltos
transition, and uh what's the other one?
Voltos U-turn.
So these are the main things I'll be
talking about. Obviously the main one is
the articles trader which is the volume
footprint chart. But anyway they that
said uh let's jump into some charts. So
this morning in the
crude crude was all over the place
honestly this morning if uh you know
you're getting a lot of signals bullish
bearish and it was really jumping around
it it seemed but at 839 just 40 you got
this low you you touched your low that
you had made earlier you made the low
here at
7:00 you touched it again now the second
time yeah you have more volume first
time it was 300 you know 269 here. It's
a little bit less. It's 176, but you got
this big selling imbalance,
537. So, and what's causing this big
selling
imbalance is you're coming down into the
low. You know, we hit the low and, you
know, bounced up a little bit, come back
down, going sideways, going sideways.
And, you know, the market is probing it.
You know, if we could break out, you
know, below 48.50. And so, you got some
very aggressive sellers here. You got
this stack, not stacked, you got a sound
of balance, the
537. You down here, you got 175 trade at
the low and it cannot get any lower.
Instead, it bounces up. You got
aggressive buying coming in here. You
got 1 2 3 four buying imbalances in this
bar. You have a divergence. You got the
positive
delta at the transition. You got point
of control near the bottom. You know,
this alone is is is a nice bar, a nice
setup bar as as a as a long. Then the
next bar, say you're not convinced, the
next bar, you got the ratio. You know,
I've been putting it out
there. You know, I've been telling
everybody if you, you know, you have the
divergence, look for a ratio in that bar
or the next bar. Here you have it in the
next
bar. And you also have the delta surge.
So, you know, delta's were just here
around the low. All of a sudden, it's
really picking up. You know, you got 11,
163, 860.
So, if you're not convinced in this bar
here, this bar is is the dead giveaway.
And we got a nice little move up, you
know, 4860 area up to, you know, around
the 48 I say 4880 cuz you're not going
to sell it up there. But you had, you
know, you could have gotten something
out of this. You know, maybe you would
have got scared up here and and sold
around 74
75 for a quick 15
ticks. Then, you know, he started coming
off. You got the delta surge here again.
You know, delta's picking up as you come
into the
low. Excuse me. And you we just go
sideways. Okay, we make a new low. Yeah,
whoopee. Make a new low by a tick. Big
deal. But what's important is a couple
things. One, you got point of control Y
at the bottom. It's a green bar and it's
a ratio. You know, it's a ratio of uh.3.
So, it's indicating some stopping volume
down there. You got the big negative
delta. Okay. Now, you know, ask
yourself what what does that
mean? You know, what does all this mean?
Here you have this, you know, big number
here 1373. There's obviously support.
So, if we're going to test this level,
which we did later, you know, is this
support still going to be there? And
more importantly, if this support is
still going to be there, what's going to
happen when we get through it? Okay, so
anyway, we rally up here. We go from
this this low, we rally up. We got a
bearish sign up here. We got imbalance
at the high. That's this red arrow
indicating, you know, the look for the
next bar or two to sell off. Just as you
have this buying buying imbalance down
here, the 460, sorry, selling imbalance
here, 463 with the red arrow. Again, you
got a ratio. So, we've come back down to
this level. There is some volume there.
We rally half-heartedly. Boom. Get
slammed again. Now, watch when we get
back down to this level. 878 lots trade.
Okay. So, you know,
400, we'll call it 500 plus 800 is
1300. So, there's about 2 and a half
thousand lots bid here. 48 uh what is
that? 48 4850. Okay.
Now, two there's two ways to look at it.
One, you have support. Yes, you do. But
if you get through this support, you
know, the floodgates can open. You know,
if this orders is filled there, what's
going to happen? What's left to support
the
market? Probably nothing. And what
happens? Boom. You get through the last
800. And look at this stack selling a
balance here. Here, this is what you
know, this is like a stop being
triggered. And you can see how fast it
is. Is that 945 945 these two bars here.
This is what a stop
induced imbalance looks like. Yeah, just
all zeros. All
zeros. Lots of times you get the
pullback immediately. In this case, you
don't. It just keeps, you know, the
selling just keeps coming in and we
pound down into these lows here, new
lows, 48.20. So, it's about a 30 cent
move. And you get down here and you got
your last, you know, your last selling
imbalances. You got the green bar. Bar
market starts turning up. Selling a
balance, selling imbalance. And again,
you know, like I said, look for this,
you know, in the next bar or two for,
you know, you know, a move and you start
getting it here. You can see it here. We
rally up. Um, sort of go sideways and
eventually we we, you know, rally back
all the way up to 50. Um, this is the
Delta Scalper giving a buy
here, you know, and it's just uh
straight up literally from there with
without much resistance on on the way
back all the way up all the way back up
to the 49 buck area.
Um, you know, then sort of go sideways
and make another move a little bit later
towards the end of the day. But that was
the, you know, that that was the
interesting trade was really that wanted
at 8
uh 830. Um, yeah. You know, I I would
like the move to be bigger. Everyone's
going to say, "Oh, you know, it's a 15
cent move. Big deal." Yeah.
Okay. Well, you know, not not all your
you know, not all your trades are going
to be beauty pad winners. Um, you know,
I like crystal clear trade setups that,
you know, whether they give me, you
know, five ticks, 10 ticks, 20 ticks,
100 ticks, um, they give me
something. Okay. So, the next market
I'll talk about is the S&Ps. This is a
10 range chart now. And you can see, you
know, this green line is the high. This
red line is the low. So, you know, at
this time, this is 9:00. Very, very
tight range. 87 and 1/2 high, 81 low,
you know, 6 and 12 points. And to move
from your high to your low is going to
be about a, you know, it's about three
bars. So, we had this high here at, you
know, finished at 921. You have a
divergence. You don't have a ratio. You
got the ratio in the next bar, which I
like. Of course, the only problem
is we're, you know, we have such a a
tight range. Where is this market going
to go? So if you're getting short here
off of this ratio and this divergence,
you know, you're getting short in this
bar. Okay. So to, you know, get anything
out of this trade, you got to go into
the lows, make new lows. Now, can you do
it? Of course you can. Uh market makes
news highs and and lows all the time,
every day. But, you know, you run the
risk of, let's say, there's a risk. You
might you run into the reality that, you
know, there could be support or there
could be resistance. You know, going
down there could be support showing up
below the lows or above the highs. There
could be resistance. Um, in this case,
we're going into the lows. And you can
see there's there's decent volumes down
here. Um, yeah, we make new lows, which
is good, encouraging, strong negative
delta. Yet, the delta surge kept kicking
off right there. But, you know, you see
these volumes, 5,000, 4,000. um 4,000
6,000 4,000 you know 2,000 2,000 and you
just go sideways. You do you know again
you know you sell off from 83 down to 79
eventually get down to 78 and 3/4 um you
know a new low you know you're you're
vindicated that yeah you know we made
new lows but there wasn't
much there beyond uh you know underneath
those lows there is some there is some
support down here. Um, even down here
when you're coming into these new lows,
you see 4,000, 3,700,
3,300,600. Um, you got a divergence down
here. This is the price rejector. This
blue line here, this one's the delta
uh surge. This is the delta scalper. It
reads different things in in the
delta. And, you know, we rally from our
low right back up to our highs. And you
know, we made new highs that that that's
nice. Um, you got a ratio. You don't
have a divergence. Still got the
positive delta. Came off a little bit.
You know, you got this bar here. It's
kind of bearish. You got this buying
imbalance. You know, we hit the high,
come off, start rallying back up. People
are excited, thinking we're going to
take the market higher. It doesn't go
higher. You got some selling coming in.
Imbalances, imbalances. And you know we
do go lower from you know the 85ish area
down to 83 but you know we rally back a
little bit late in the session and uh
you know this is just you know 5 6:00
Chicago time right here in the evening
session right now. But um you know it
was this was a nice setup. The only
problem with it was we're such a tight
range
that you know when you're in tight range
sometimes it it's good and bad. You
know, one is good. I like being in a
tight range because, you know, that's
where big moves come out of. Oftent
times, big moves will occur after you've
been trading in a tight range, but at
the same time, you know, you don't know
that if if you're going to still sitting
in the tight range. Um, and here you got
a sell signal right in the middle of
your range. Okay? So, it's not like, you
know, you're
um you know, you're you're breaking out
of this range that you've been in all
all night, you know? No, you're in the
middle of the range getting a sell
signal which isn't normally I'll say
very effective but you know isn't
usually the best place to be taking
trades is in the middle of the value
area in the middle of your you know
right around your point of control for
the day and you know in in in the middle
of of your range basically. You know you
can have the best trading indicator in
the world but if it's in the in the
middle of a range you know of a market
that's going nowhere it's probably not
going to be very effective. So, you
know, that was the only drawback on this
on this setup here was just that we had
been in the sixpoint range and it's
happening right in the middle of the
range. Okay. So, the next market I'll
talk about is fiveear notes. Again, this
is the uh four range chart. And you know
what was interesting this morning?
Again, you know, very tight range, but
you know, this blue line I've had up
there since uh I think two days 11809 is
is my level. you know, that's a level
that we had as uh support or resistance.
For a while, it was support or sorry, it
was resistance because, you know, there
was 20 thou, you know, about 35,000 lots
that had traded there in a short period.
And you know, that's significant volume.
And if we're going to finally get
through that, you know, it's going to
become my resistance level, which it was
for most of
yesterday. And then we got up late
yesterday. We got up through that level
and then, you know, overnight we just
sort of hung around that level you most
of the night, got above it. Um, you
know, coming into 4 in the morning
Chicago time. Yeah, you traded down
through it. You can see some buying
appeared back here. Um, you know, just
uh at the 09 level, another 3,000,
another 4,000, one tick
below.
And you know, coming into this was at
845. You know, this bar here I found
very interesting. You had this very
strong negative delta just off the high.
Sorry, very strong positive delta. It's
7,580. At one point it was
9,444. You know, a delta like this, you
expect the market, you know, don't look
at the bar, okay? Just look at the
delta. Strong delta like this, you
expect this market to, you know, not be
selling off. You expect it to be trading
twelves, 13s, you know, over the next
bar. But what happened is, you know,
selling came in late. It got whacked
pretty good here. You got a couple
selling imbalances. But, you know, the
reason why you have the strong buying uh
delta cuz you know the volume here 1,800
3400 5,000
4,000 you know people were buying it.
people were buying it um you know
looking for the breakout it which never
came and instead it got pounded down but
you know which is kind of bearish you
know the fact that you got that strong
ne positive delta but the negative bar
you know the red bar next bar you see
more selling pressure here you see you
got a racial bounds low got 3,400
2100 and then you know more selling
comes in now the only problem with this
is I know that at
11809 I have support. You know, there
were buyers there, you know, for the
past couple days. Even this morning as
you got down here to 09, you know, there
was some buying, you know, and it's just
a level that we can if we start hugging
it, you know, we can just be trading,
you know, rotating around that level.
And in this case, we got down within a
tick above. We got down to 9 and a
quarter. We see some decent volume
stepping up here, 3,000,
5,000. And then we just shoot back. we
shoot up um you know we react to this
level and we start you know the buying
comes in we get all the way up here um
we start to come off we had an auction
there was a 7-year note auction
and you know right around 12:00 that's
why you see a lot of stuff going through
here um you know this bar with thin
volume and you know we do make the new
high but now with with that in mind you
know very tight range here I'm going to
pull up the bond chart
because you know the bonds were a bit
interesting. So you know just mark this
time here
9:15. Okay that we start rallying up
here. I think it was
9:15. Where am
I?
Yeah. So at
9:15 we're right in here in this bar
just off the lows in the bonds. Okay,
this is 918. But you know, maybe I
should put these side by side a little
bit easier to step
through. But we come into these highs
here. Where were the highs being
made? You know, 933 to 948. 94. You
know, this between 9:30 and 9:45. We're
making new highs here quite
aggressively. you know, got this big bar
here, big strong positive
delta. And where are bonds at this time?
We're trading right around here, um,
around 15216. So, almost in the middle
of our range. You know, it was 28 was
the high at that time. And, you know,
obviously the low is 07. We're trading
16. So, obviously 5 years outperforming
the the 30 years.
And you know, I'm not usually a big
advocate of looking for, you know, when
5 years are making highs, look for bonds
to all of a sudden start rallying. But
when bonds are way off our highs, far
enough away, you know, there there could
be the potential for some catchup. Okay?
So even if at 9:48, you know, in this
bar, when this bar closes, you know, you
you clearly made new highs by, you know,
1 2 3 4 5 ticks. And at 9:48, you know,
we're trading here around, you know, 20.
Was that 23? Our high is up here at 28.
So, we're still five points away. And,
you know, we do get all the way up
there, make new highs all the way up
till 11:00. So, but honestly, I mean,
realistically, excuse
me, you know, here at 9:43 is when you
could have been getting in
here around 16. I'd been talking about
this in my room as it was happening.
There was plenty of time to getting in
around this 1617 level, not up here at
the 23. Um so there was there was a you
know something to be had in that market
in the bonds um following the five
years. Normally I'm not that big a fan
of it but when it's far enough away you
were at that point it seemed were closer
to the lows than to the highs. Well 5
years we're making new
highs. Okay. This is something I haven't
talked about in a while. This is the
U-turn. Um, I know I haven't actually I
haven't talked about how you turn on 100
tick chart. I've talked about transition
before. Again, you know, I'm just
showing it to you on the uh on the bar
chart. You can run this indicator on a
bar
chart. You don't necessarily need a
footprint chart, but still, you know, it
makes it a little easier for your
analysis. Now, 7:00. Yeah, you had a
sell signal up here, but again, it's 7
o'clock before the cash
opens. I prefer the uh mini dot when the
cash opens, you know. So, here you got a
nice sell signal. came off. Here was a
buy that failed. You know, here's a buy.
You know, you got it started moving and
then it failed. Here's a nice little
buy. A little something
here again. You know, nice little buy
here. I don't think this this shouldn't
have stopped you out. A couple sells
that failed. This one you probably
wouldn't have been taken. This was a
nice little sell here down to this
area. Um, you know, this one didn't work
out. Again, nice sell here to this buy.
you know, from this buy, you get a nice
little move up there. Um, you know, now
I I know some people are going to say,
"Oh, you had you got these losing trades
here." You know, you're losing trade
here. You know, this this indicator
sucks. Um, you know, everyone wants the
indicator. It gives you a buy here and a
sell here, okay? Or and then a sell here
and a buy here. You know, people don't
want these losing trades, but you know
what? In trading, you have losing
trades. That's just the uh reality of of
of trading. Um, you know, I could sit
here and show you just perfect
charts of, you know, buying on the low,
selling on the high, and, you know, just
cherry pick them, but, you know, I'm
trying to show you stuff, you know, that
happens every day. Okay, so this is the
transition um, this morning. Again, you
got to sell here. It looked like it was
going to work out. I would have popped
back up here, stopped out. Then you got
a nice move here, you know, from 9:15
all the way up to the 940 area before it
sells off. People say, "Well, you know,
you should have a sell signal up here."
Well, there there's not in the order
flow, right? The transition, these
indicators read the order flow. If
there's nothing in the order flow, it's
not going to give you a signal. That's
the reality of it. Um, you know, here
started to work out, it came back out.
You know, trail your stop, you're
stopped out at a small loss or break
even here. You get a nice little move up
here. This one you shouldn't have taken
um because it didn't give you
confirmation to get into the trade. I'm
not going to get into the trade setup.
I'm just trying to show you the quick uh
indication, the quick uh trades how they
work. You know, this one a nice little
something, but it gives you a buy signal
here. This one you wouldn't have taken.
This one you could have got something
out of. You know, that was that was it.
So, that was the transition today on the
100 tick mini Dow chart. Now, the other
market uh that I could talk about a
little bit today, but I'm not going to
really talk much is is the Euro
currency. Now, reason I'm not going to
talk much about the Euro currency is
because here the ECB announcement and
you know that's just going to give you
an incredible amount of volatility in
this currency. So, um, you know, you're
going to get whipssaw moves very fast.
And again, you know,
most traders, you know, this is where
this is where
people, you know, beginning traders uh,
suffer is because they think, oh, you
know, hey, there's an ECB announcement.
That's great. It's adding volatility to
the market. Yeah, it adds volatility.
And volatility more often than not works
against the a beginning trader.
um you know you're not most of us are
not economists. You have an ECB
announcement and then you have a press
conference afterwards where um you know
Drag is talking
about you know his thoughts on on the
the EU and you know his policy and you
know for us this you know to be trading
during that time is is is is pointless.
um you know wait for the market to
settle down because you can see how you
know these bars are are super fast you
know 1 second 2 seconds each bar is
forming um and I said you know like I
said most of us are not economists you
know look at this time from
736 and 38 seconds
here to 738 and 20 seconds you know
you're getting a move from 30 all the
way up to almost you know the 56 um you
know and back down again and and again
you know 738 22 seconds is, you know, 8
9 seconds is this entire chart right
here, you know, from this price movement
from, you know, 32 up to 52. You know,
again, it's it's a time to sit back,
watch the
market, wait till it settles down, and
wait till the press conference is over.
Yeah, you're gonna say, "Well, you know,
this great big move. I want to get
involved." and but oftentimes, you know,
you're rushing to get involved and and
you take the wrong trade and in the end
it just costs you money. Um, he said,
you know, when I was on the floor,
right, this was back in the 90s. I
learned very early on who
participates during rate
announcements is not the big
institutional traders, it's the retail
traders. You know, people scrambling on
their positions is what causes a lot of
them this volatility. you know, the the
big macro traders, you know, they have
their views already of the markets and
they're not going to say, "Oh my gosh,
you know, ECB left rates unchanged. I I
got to dump my position." No, they're
going to wait to see how it plays out
over the next day or two and, you know,
see if if market is settled down and if
it's going to continue in the correct
direction. I mean, most of these these
big macro traders are already aligned
with what uh you know, Draghi was going
to say anyway, you know, leaving rates
unchanged. But you know there what they
do then is they start parsing out what
he's saying in his you know in the press
conference afterwards. And believe me
you know these people that are parsing
it out you know the these traders
they're they're a lot sharper than the
majority of of retail traders. It's not
to say, you know, there's brilliant
retail traders out there that can um
understand what Draggy's message is and
you know what he's he's thinking, but
again, you know, you're just, you know,
I hate to say you're just the noise in
the market, but you know, most retail
traders, myself included, um you know,
that's why I don't trade during this
time is because, you know, I'm not
sitting there glued to, you know, every
word he's saying, you know, and and I
don't have a big research team behind
me, you know, like like a banks have
research teams and everyone, you know,
they got a bunch of people analyzing
what he's saying and coming up with
their conclusions and putting it out
there for people to make, you know,
trade recommendations to their clients
and the clients to start trading on. You
know, it's that's not something that
happens immediately. You know, there's
the press conference, you know, the
analysts go over what what was said, you
know, they put out the recommendations,
you know, later that day, that night,
the next day, you know, and then then
you're going to get the moves happening.
you know what you're getting right now
is just the volatility of people
scrambling to cover their positions um
you know getting stopped out all all
sorts of things like that again I'm not
saying you can't trade during that time
of course you can trade during that time
you know people trade but you know the
majority of the retail traders that are
trading during that time I I feel are
just scrambling for their positions
because you got a lot of volatility
markets moving up moving down people are
getting you know their stops getting hit
and things like that and they're wonder
what the hell's going on you know the
market's rigged all this garbage. Um,
it's not, you know, it's the added
volatility and this is, you know, there
are certain days of the month that you
shouldn't be involved in the market. You
know, you could, you don't have to trade
the market every single day. You know,
people are action junkies if, you know,
there's something that's potentially
going to add volatility to the market.
Now, there's, you know, different ways
to look at it. Yeah, volatility helps
you get the moves, but at the same time,
you
know, it it can also damage you. Um, you
know, so do you want to be trading in in
a market that can damage you? No. Um,
you know, later in the day, you know, it
did settle down a bit, you know, after
9:00 after the press conference and then
you start to see some, you know, more
normal moves. You know, here's a nice
three in a row, a little bit of a
pullback and and a move higher. Um, go
sideways. You know, you get the single
print here at the sing at the swing
high. um you know you got more more
natural moves rather than just sort of
jumping all over the place. But, you
know, really, you know, there's days of
the month that that I don't really have
interest in in trading or following. I
say following, but um you know, trading,
you know, non-farm payroll days is one.
Um you know, Fed announcement, FOMC
meeting announcements. um you know
around the time the minutes come out and
ECB announcements you know it's not like
it's every day that you know there's
some major thing coming out but you know
and in the grains the uh supply and
demand report you know let the report
come out you know supply and demand
report is you know if if you follow
grains um you know that's the that's the
big thing on the calendar and you get
incredible volatility during that time
and you know it's just it's just better
to you know save your bullets you know
fight another day. Um, you know, just
because you have, oh, we got ECB, you
know, when when I was a young gun, you
know, young trader, I used to think, oh
yeah, we got this ECB announcement
coming out. But then I realized, you
know, by working and hanging around
traders at the time, you know, who are
the ones trading, it's it's not the big
guys trading, you know, they're not
dumping, oh my gosh, you know, used to
be left rates unchanged, sell the
portfolio. No, it's not like that, you
know. They said, "Okay." You know, and
then they go, "Okay, let me get to the
office." You know, because
ECB announcement is 6:45 Chicago time.
You know, a lot of guys don't get into
the office till, you know, back when the
the floor was open. A lot of guys don't
get until after 7. And, you know, it's
okay. You know, they're already
positioned. Um, you know, I mean, the
consensus was that they're going to be
unchanged anyway. So, you know, the big
traders are okay. you know, when I get
back into the office, you know,
especially people on the uh West Coast,
you know, I'll take a look at it. You
know, it doesn't necessarily mean
they're going to all of a sudden
readjust their entire portfolio. No, of
course not. But, um, you know, less
lesser people would would have you I'll
say lesser people. Um, you know, other
people would would have you believe
that, you know, people that haven't been
training professionally, you know,
trading at institutions, you know, don't
don't necessarily understand that. You
know, I I
I would be out to dinner with guys from
in Singapore, you know, guys worked at
MAS, Monetary Authority of Singapore in
GIC, which is the government investment
corpus Singapore. And these are massive,
massive funds, you know, hundreds of
billions of dollars of public money. You
know, these people are asset managers.
And you know, numbers would come out
because it'd be nighttime in Singapore
on Friday night. you know, the
unemployment
number and, you know, just be enjoying a
nice uh a nice dinner and, you know, get
a call from, you know, the trading desk.
Oh, yeah. You came out here. Okay. What
are Euro dollars doing?
Okay. Um, you know, right now, you know,
they're up six ticks or something. Okay,
call me back in 10 minutes. Okay. They
call back 10 minutes. Where is it now?
Okay. You know, maybe buy a thousand.
You know, do something like that. But
it's not like all a sudden, oh, they're
they're in fast market or anything like
that. know, you know, they they already
know coming into what's going to happen.
Um, so they're not necessarily reactive.
They're more proactive, if that makes
sense. And I I know what I'm just
talking about for five last five minutes
makes no sense to a lot of people, but
again, some people, you'll understand
it. Again, the best way to explain it is
when I was on the floor back in the
early '9s, Fed started hiking rates. And
when you look around at the the phone
banks, the only phones that were
ringing, the majority of the phones, let
me rephrase that. Majority of phones
that were ringing were the retail
brokers, the Refcos, um you know,
the Lyn Waldocks, you know, th those
companies, the the retail brokers, those
were the ones that were extremely busy,
you know, the institutional dealers, the
ARB guys doing nothing, you know, just
just watching, you know, see the market,
waiting for it to settle down, and then
they're going to jump back in. So, you
know, don't think that just because, oh,
there's a ECB rate announcement, I got
to be involved in the market. No, it's
actually quite the opposite. you'll
you'll do better in the long run saving
your bullets for um you know when
there's uh you know better truer I'll
say truer moves but you know moves that
are are happening naturally rather than
read knee-jerk reactions I know people
are going to say oh you know
you know you don't know what you're
talking about fine you don't have to
believe me keep trading the way you're
trading keep losing money the way you're
losing money and you know go about your
way um you know not everything I say is
going to resonate with people I'm just
speaking from my years and years of
experience. Um, you know, a lot of
people that are going to sit there and
complain, oh, you don't know what you're
saying. You know, I I've never traded
professionally, you know, like I'm I'm
not trying to brag or anything like
that. No, not at all. You know, but I
traded for 20 years at top firms. You
don't last 20 years at top firms if you
don't know what you're doing and you
don't know how to manage risk.
And you know, people, you know, the
first ones that throw bullets are are
the ones that are are losing money. Um,
you know, throw bullets. The one that
throw stones, you know, are the ones
that are losing money. They don't
understand the markets, think they know
everything. And, you know, these are the
ones that, you know, go spend all their
time in in trading forums and talking
smack when somebody posts a comment, you
know, talk smack, you know, about them.
You don't know what you're doing. Listen
to me. I know what I'm doing. It's like
the guy that goes to the casino with his
wife, you know, has $5,000, sits down at
a blackjack table, thinks he's the
greatest blackjack player in the world.
Okay, his wife asks, "Hey, can I have
some money?" Gives her $100 to go play
the slot machines. And you know, she
comes back an hour later, "Oh, honey, I
lost I lost my money. Can I have some
more money?" And then he goes all
berserk on her. Oh, you don't know what
you're doing. You don't know how to
gamble. Blah blah blah. You lost $100.
And then, you know, in the meantime,
he's down 5,000. you know, he's down
$3,000 out of his $5,000 at the
blackjack table. You know, those are the
type of
people that are out there that spend
their time on trading
forms. Anyway, I digress again.
[Music]
Um, and this this recording has sort of
gone off the off the wheels, honestly.
But, um, you know, thanks for watching
this. If you want to learn more about
trading with Orderflow, visit my
website,
orderflows.com. And you I've been
getting a lot of questions lately about
a lot of things. If if I got time today,
tomorrow, this weekend, I I've got to uh
I'll address them in a video top 10
questions. And thanks. Visit my website,
orderflows.com. Bye-bye.